former CNN chairman and Time magazine
managing editor Walter Isaacson is
author of the new biography Benjamin
Franklin and American Life he spoke
about it recently for about an hour
thank you so much Baris I was very nice
and it's an absolute joy just wonderful
to be back in Philadelphia after many
many visits to Philadelphia doing this
book every one of them you feel suffused
with the excitement the life the legacy
of Benjamin Franklin especially when
you're in a great library like this
since he helped found the notion of
great libraries in America this and the
library company in the American
Philosophical Society and so many great
institutions of the city whenever I come
back to the city I love just starting at
the very end of Market Street like he
did right at the wharf there and walking
up those blocks of Market Street and
thinking of him straggling off the boat
all wet and bedraggled and it's a
wonderful scene the greatest of all
scenes in autobiographical literature of
course he's got those two coins in his
pocket he gives one of them to the
boatman as a tip for helping rowing they
try not to take it because he had helped
grow and you know he insists that they
take it and he uses the others to buy
the famous three puffy rolls and gives
one of them to the hungry woman who had
been on this boat and delightfully he
says you're always more generous when
you're poor because you don't want
people to think you're poor and so you
pretend to be more generous and that was
sort of like him always concerned about
doing good doing well by doing good but
also appearing to be a great man as well
and it's that wonderful mixture of the
appearances but the appearances that are
deeply rooted in a reality of a generous
pragmatic decent guy and also when you
have that scene and you look at the
manuscript of the scene and he then adds
a little something about how Deborah
read the young girl was standing there
laughing at him as he walks up the
street here of Market Street thinking
that he made a ridiculous appearance and
then Franklin heads in as indeed I did
he
is that wonderful self-deprecation and
so then you reflect on the fact that
it's not only this wonderful scene but
you think of Benjamin Franklin years
later you know in his 60s at a summer
house in England writing this scene and
mixing in all the wonderful notes of
image and self-deprecation sort of
trying to remind his Tory sympathizing
aristocratic son to remember the roots
that they came from that he was middle
class or we'd the middling people as he
liked to say that we shouldn't try to
create an aristocracy here in America
but we should build a new nation based
on people like himself who had been
diligent hard-working shopkeepers and so
that scene in that walk-up Market Street
and just seeing all the institutions
that grew up around him here just makes
you think of not only the greatness of
the man but that real human quality I
mean the other founding fathers people
sometimes ask you know why drive by
Frank well the other founding fathers
you know they're all up there and marble
carved in marble on a pedestal this guy
is flesh and blood and people say gee
you know he had a problem with his son
and his marriage was sort of you know
not always perfect and so don't you have
problems with that and you say wait a
minute
you know people like that you know we're
all flesh-and-blood humans and at least
this is a founder that you can relate to
and especially when you're breathing the
air of Philadelphia of course he doesn't
really start here he starts in Boston
and as a wonderful self-taught kid he
was a tenth son of somebody candlemaker
from Boston and his father was the bus
gonna make him the tithe to the Lord
send him to study for the ministry at
Harvard fortunately perhaps Benjamin
Franklin was not exactly cut for the
cloth one day they were assaulting away
all the provisions for the winter and
putting him away and young Benjamin
Franklin said why don't I say grace over
them right now we get it done with once
and for all for the year
so his father realized there would be a
darn waste of money to send him to
Harvard it's probably the best thing
ever to happen to him instead he has to
become self-taught this is why he loves
libraries of course his older brother
was apprentice gets apprenticed to his
older brother and so he gets to borrow
overnight some of the books from the
booksellers that they print the books
for and there he is at age 12 and 13 you
know taking these books and trying to
teach himself and remembering each one
of them you know Plutarch's lives he
reads and Bunyan's Pilgrim's Progress
and all those books that all of us were
reading when we were 12 and 13 years old
and he decides he's got to make himself
a great writer too because he wants to
be a writer and what he does is he takes
old copies of The Spectator that great
British magazine and he reads the essays
by Addison and Steele and takes notes on
them then put some notes aside and
occasionally recreates the essay in
poetry so he can increase his vocabulary
and then finally tries to replicate the
original essay from his notes or from
the poetry and compare it with the
original to see how well he did and to
correct himself when he felt he hadn't
been able to replicate the argument
quite as well and then he said every now
and then though I did feel that just in
one or two particulars I was able not
only to recreate the argument for it but
perhaps even improve it which made me
think I would be a tolerable writer well
he not only became a tolerable writer
but the best writer in America of his
time and the first writer in America
really to have that wonderful folksy
straightforward pragmatic practical
conversational style yeah be that as it
is may his brother being an older
brother and there's a way older brothers
are good jealous of them did not want
him to write for the newspaper so young
Ben Franklin now about 15 or 16 years
old decides to create a pseudonym and
secretly submit essays for the paper
very famously of course disguising his
handwriting writing under the name of
silence do-good now this is a very say
cheeky perhaps even
let's say brandy or something 15 16
year-old kid who's never spent the night
outside of Boston writing as if he's a
widowed woman living in the countryside
of Mann and Massachusetts a great
triumph of the imagination a widow who's
being courted by a minister in the most
ridiculous fashion so you think wow this
guy has a great imagination but not only
does he have a great imagination and a
wonderful spunky sense of humor but each
one of these silence do-good essays of
this young kid has a real point to it
the point that helps create what America
is all about
first essay he talks about or silence
do-good talks about how she has an
aversion to tyranny and any trampling of
her rights makes her blood boil
exceedingly and it's that notion of
liberty and freedom that's going to
become part of the American character
and then of course since Boston's a
theocracy at that point you know a
Puritan run a Commonwealth the first
great crusading against the notion of
church and state being together instead
of having a separation and there's
silence do-good poking fun at governor
dudley for being a clergyman who goes
into government and saying anybody who
is first a clergyman can rob all your
money that way and then take all your
money in government it's a worse form of
hypocrisy and that's all we have to end
it
but you you know and it's so delightful
but you have to read it carefully to see
oh yes we're creating a new nation here
even in this mind of this young 16 year
old a nation built on religious
tolerance on a separation of church and
state and aversion to tyranny all of
these things which you'll be happy those
of you here in Philadelphia to know was
not exactly the way everybody in Boston
felt whether it be his brother or the
ruling authorities in Boston who a
couple times tried to shut down the
newspaper so finally of course benjamin
franklin runs away to come down here to
Market Street eventually and be a
runaway apprentice trying to make his
name as a leather apron shop keeper here
in Philadelphia and it's great that he
comes
here because it helps reinforce this
core notion that I feel is at the heart
of what Benjamin Franklin is about and
why it's so relevant in a century this
century in which the fight against
religious intolerance and the fight for
pluralism and against fanaticism is the
core fight of our century around the
world and in all places where it's
challenged he comes to Philadelphia and
it gets reinforced because here you have
a city a city of brotherly love as the
name is implies in which they're not
it's not just a Puritan theocracy but
they're Congregationalists and
Presbyterians and Anglicans and also
Moravians and Jews and people of all
faiths all working together and he just
thrives in that element because he
becomes a little shopkeeper he
understands how to serve customers he
understands the tolerance the notion of
pragmatism the notion of compromise of
even making a deal that comes from being
a shopkeeper
serving a diverse clientele and that's
what instills in him some of these great
notions that he gives to us as a nation
and you take the very first newspaper I
mean you know here's a town of 1012
thousand people had two newspapers he
felt he wanted to start a third soon it
has many newspapers would that we had
many newspapers in our big cities today
but they he believed in that voice that
many voices the competing voices the
diversity of voices that came from a
robust presence he takes over a
newspaper and in one of his first
editorials somebody complained about not
liking something that had been in the
paper and he writes apology for Prentiss
a great editorial in which he says
basically you're not gonna like
everything it's put it in this paper but
by the way if printers only printed
things that everybody liked they'd be
very little printed in this world today
because people's opinions are as varied
in his diverse as their faces and those
of us people like himself creating a new
nation based on the free flow of
information and the free discussion of
ideas he said you know we believe that
when all sides are heard and with truth
and false
the all half-fare play that the people
are going to be smart enough and truth
will triumph over falsity and once again
it was that underlying tolerance and
pragmatism that leads them to the notion
of a raucous free press in a press that
tries to allow the people that believes
in the people that if the people have
many voices the people are smart enough
to decide instead of having sensors a
gatekeepers telling them what they have
to think of course he also believes that
a responsibility came with that he tells
a wonderful tale but if somebody tried
to get him to print something that he
found too scurrilous and not true but
was going to give him a lot of money to
print it and so he said I went home and
I bought a little loaf of bread and made
myself a gruel of bread and water and
just ate that for a day and slept on my
great coat instead of sleeping on a bed
just slept on the floor on a coat and I
realized I didn't need the money that
badly I was never gonna compromise my
principles or do things just for money
and that that responsibility comes with
the press as well and those of us who
are journalists or recovering
journalists whatever I am you know need
to remember that both the duties and the
responsibilities and the joy and the
exuberance that comes from an open press
in a society that allows the clash and
the free flow of ideas that is so
fundamental to our democracy once again
it's something that on these streets of
Philadelphia Franklin understood
intuitively and helped in doubt to this
nation he also created for himself
because he really believed that the
middling people the middle-class people
were going to be the backbone of a new
nation that if he could get the
tradesmen and the shopkeepers and the
artisans of Philadelphia to engage in
self-improvement to be a little bit
better and more diligent it would help
create a stronger society so he comes up
with all of his virtues the virtues he
is going to teach himself and then try
to have the other people in his group
learn and he makes a wonderful list of
12 virtues of industry and frugality and
all the things you need to be a
successful shopkeeper and citizen and
he's very proud of it and he works on it
every week marking down
he had done on each one of these virtues
eventually putting on a piece of slate
he said because in his wonderful
self-deprecating style
he loves to poke fun at himself he said
I had to put it on piece of slate
because I was making so many marks and
it was you know working through the
paper of the notebook that he needed a
slate where he could erase some of the
marks and start clean again but he
finally gets it right he gets these
virtues and he's showing it around to
his friends and one of his friends
kindly informed him that he's left off a
virtue that he might want to have and
Franklin says what's that and the friend
says humility
perhaps you should add that one to your
list and Franklin of course adds
humility to the list and says I was
never able to conquer this virtue I was
never able to master humility but I was
very good at the appearance of it I was
I could fake it I could feign humility
and but here's the key part with the
appearance and the underlying reality as
is at least in my mind the theme of
Franklin's life joined together and he
said the appearance of humility and
caring about humility and showing
humility was in many ways as important
as the real thing it caused you to
listen to other people to care about
what they thought to realize you may be
fallible to realize you may have to make
compromise and I often think of America
in this world today you know and George
Bush talked very eloquently about the
need for humility in our foreign policy
and after the terrorist attacks I think
quite rightly and understandably the
country and President Bush in the
administration had a more assertive
foreign policy but now after we've done
so there's a question of at least
perhaps we could fake a bit of humility
and listen to some of our allies so you
get some coalition's together to help us
I think it would have at least helped
people in the world feel that we care
what they think about so even if we
can't truly have humility as the world's
great superpower
perhaps we could be like Franklin and
fake it a little bit better he also had
a wonderful as you can tell
humor and I think that humor also in a
way comes from the humility and the
sense of tolerance and everything else
because it was a special type of humor
that became the American style of humor
was a new type of humor in many ways it
was that folksy sort of naive character
like silence do-good or later poor
Richard or many of the other pseudonyms
he invented folksy and naive and
feigning a little bit of innocence but
with a sharp and wicked pen that's
poking fun at the powerful and the
pretensions of the elite and at the
arrogance and stuff with a little self
deprecation thrown in the type of humor
you've seen in everything from Mark
Twain to Will Rogers to the present that
is very American because it gives a
sense of community and tolerance and
that sort of good-natured poking at the
powerful that keeps American democracy
so healthy you see it in so many of his
pieces and he combines it with the
notion of religious tolerance and
everything else there's a witch trial at
Mount Holly which I love a little tale
he wrote these are all kind of hoaxes
that half the time people thought were
real stories and only a few years later
or many years later realize they were
hoaxes by Benjamin Franklin
but the witch trial at Mount Holly is
[ __ ] funded religious intolerance
where they decide to see if some people
are witches they're accused so they're
gonna dump them in the river and if they
sink it means they're actually innocent
but if they float it means they're
witches which seem like a no-win
proposition but those who are accused
said well that's fine but you have to
throw the accusers in as well and see so
they throw them all into the river and
most of them float and Franklin or his
narrator says with the wry wit of
Franklin some of the people kind of
figured out that maybe it just meant
that human beings naturally float but
others weren't so sure and they decided
they'd try it again in the summertime
when they could do it without clothes to
see who floated who's saying and even
poking fun of the double standards that
happened at the time Benjamin Franklin
was a father of an illegitimate child
William a very interesting character
as I said was the guy who became
somewhat aristocratic pretentious
loyalist to the crown and Franklin was
sort of half aiming the first part of
his autobiography at him but he does a
story called the trial of Polly Baker
who also had had illegitimate children
five illegitimate children but she's on
trial and she's been put in jail for it
and she kind of mentions well you know I
believe the promises that were made to
me and there are five men who and
they're not on trial and somehow I am on
trial and she gives a stirring defense
of what she has done to help the city
and how she was the one who's misled and
why is she the one on trial and said the
man and in a certain point one of the
magistrates comes down from the bench
with great emotion and proposes marriage
to her and they get married when
suspects that he may have been one of
the five I'm not quite sure but uh but
it's just this wonderful way of poking
fun at some of the pretensions of the
elite while also establishing a new feel
for what American democracy would be
about the best of all of course is the
Poor Richard's Almanack s-- which he
printed in his shop right here in Market
Street and Poor Richard's is one of his
pseudonyms and great cutouts and the
great thing about Poor Richard's who
basically his philosophy was doing well
by doing good meaning he can make a buck
by doing good for his fellow citizens he
taught a whole lot of Maxim's you know
the early to bed early to rise which I'm
not sure Franklin fully obeyed most of
his life and a penny saved is a penny
earned it was partly there to help
people the shopkeepers and tradesmen
become better citizens but his poor
Richard says in the very first preface
of the very first Almanac in 1733 he
wasn't just doing it to be helpful he
was doing it because his wife threatened
to kick him out of the house and throw
away all of his instruments and stuff if
he didn't make some money at it
eventually and so he's doing it to make
a buck as well and you see that great
style of Franklin poking fun at himself
but also being an entrepreneur who
believes you can be an entrepreneur but
also help your community and be a good
civic citizen
and that out of that eventually he
retires or semi retires from the print
trade he's franchised his shops up and
down the coast from Boston to Barbados
created a great media empire that would
be the envy of the media empires I used
to work for and others in which he had
both wonderful printing facilities and
then franchises up and down the coast
and then the content be poor richard's
almanack or his own writings of the
newspapers and then the books that he
imported to publish and then eventually
being a great media tycoon the
distribution system which he wanted to
help control so he helps create the US
postal service for that once again a
case of doing well by doing good
but he takes some time off after a while
from these partnerships because he wants
to turn himself into a great citizen and
civic leader and do well for his
community he writes his sister a
wonderful letter describing his
motivations they say fine he ends by
saying I'd rather be said of me that I
lived usefully than that he died rich
and what he does is he forms many of the
groups including the library were
sitting here and the others I talked
about that helped Philadelphia and
helped America become better communities
better towns and a greater country and
among those was the junto a great little
discussion Club which is supposed to
help you know the tradesmen of
Philadelphia discussed the important
issues of the time the timeless values
and how they apply to the problems they
were seeing at their time and just
speaking personally for a minute having
spent 20 25 years in the media world and
I was thinking making a transition it
helped me a lot too and I moved to a
place the Aspen Institute which Lawrence
mentioned which is very much modeled and
very much like the junto it's a it's in
its engaged in discussion it's engaged
in looking at values the values of art
of our civilization from Plato to the
present it brings people together from
all walks of life
who want to step back for a little while
and have a vacation for the body mind
and soul in order to recharge their
connection to their values if they've
sort of lost a feel for the value
sometimes in the business world they
feel it's good or to just discuss the
great ideas great books and great values
and how they apply to the issues of our
time and people keep coming to ask and
for these seminars and anybody I urge
you all to come here you can just go to
the website and look them up and come
but it's a type of thing that Benjamin
Franklin felt was important that you did
you didn't just try to succeed you also
tried to connect to certain values and
connect those values to the community
because in the end people were going to
judge you
not by whether you died rich but what
but by whether you lived well and served
your fellow citizen rate and of course
the library because he connected that to
his rather amorphous but deep belief in
God I think when he founded the
libraries here he had a wonderful slogan
which was basically to pour forth
benefits for the common good is divine
and that helped him figure out that even
though he didn't know which particular
religion or which particular church here
to join there was one particular Creed
he felt all churches should have which
is the best way to serve God is to do
well by your community and your fellow
citizens now that also came in the
founding of the University of
Pennsylvania and I love the difference
of the way he founded the University of
Pennsylvania and to compare it to his
friend and protege Thomas Jefferson
later found at the University of
Virginia but Jefferson felt that the
point of a university like that would be
to skim a new aristocracy to create in
his version of a meritocracy to take the
most talented people and remove them
from the rest of society elevate them
skim them off a bit and make them into
this new aristocracy not Franklin he was
the most democratic he had the best
finger to feel for democracy of all the
founders and for the University of
Pennsylvania it was to help any aspiring
person any inspiring person who was
going to be diligent and work hard
whatever their station in life to help
improve them to become better citizens
and he wasn't trying to create a
new class society or new elite but just
a better society all around in which
people from all walks of life I got a
very practical and solid a chance to be
better citizens he finally goes over to
England after that to help here's a man
of great hope for the British Empire and
he basically felt all problems could be
solved so I said about the Aspen
Institute or the junto by looking at the
underlying values and saying we can find
common ground and he mistakenly thought
that he could find a common ground that
would say the British Empire and keep
what he called the fine noble China vase
from shattering apart that's never being
able to be put back together he finally
ended up using the humor again those
hoaxes just like when he was silence
do-good one of my favorites is a
newspaper article he wrote it was after
England it imposed a lot of taxes and
tariffs and they had justified the taxes
and tariffs on the colonies for a
variety of reasons including the fact
that that colonize you know this part of
the world and they had protected against
Wars and they had the right to impose
the taxes so he wrote the edict from the
King of Prussia which appeared in the
papers it was an edict from Prussia in
which Russia announced it was imposing a
tax and tariffs on the English because
they had colonized England and protected
in certain Wars and he was in a country
home at that point in England and
somebody comes running down with the
paper and says look at this and they're
reading this thing aloud with great
outrage
that the King of Prussia would have put
out such an edict and they look at
Franklin in the corner smiling and they
realize that once again his pen his
sense of humor his way of using humor to
make a point had been so successful he
of course finally gets humiliated over
and over again in his attempt so he
comes back to America in 1775 and cast
his lot in favor of the revolution here
in what is now known as Independence
Hall of course first he has to have the
summit meeting with his son
and this is great soap opera that have
alluded to the son William the
illegitimate son the son II adored and
educated and took responsibility for and
then tried to prevent from becoming to
our Socratic by now William has become
the royal governor of New Jersey and is
very loyal to the crown and they meet up
in Bucks County for the summit and they
don't reconcile they can't get together
and Franklin declares that he's going to
be a rebel and eventually William is
arrested by George Washington's troops
and this horrible rift in the family
happens made even more poignant by this
beautiful grandson William's own son in
fact William's own illegitimate son
temple Franklin who Benjamin Franklin
the grandfather had helped educate and
raise and there was this tug-of-war for
the loyalty of Temple Franklin and of
course Benjamin Franklin wins the
tug-of-war for the loyalty of Temple and
they're there than in Philadelphia in
1776 when it comes time to write the
Declaration of Independence and it's the
greatest committee you'll ever find
three the three most important people in
the committee were Thomas Jefferson John
Adams and of course Benjamin Franklin to
write the Declaration and on Market
Street here using a little lap desk that
he invented Jefferson writes the very
first draft the initial draft of what
they're gonna do and he sends it to
Franklin a few doors away and in this
beautiful flowery letter says well the
good dr. Franklin and all of his
infinite wisdom please peruse this
document and any improvements he could
possibly make in blah blah blah
and I thought boy people are much nicer
the editors back then and Franklin sees
that famous second paragraph and
Jefferson is written we hold these
truths to be sacred and undeniable if
Franklin takes his printers pen that
wonderful black printers pen with the
Petit backslashes that a plaintiff uses
and crosses out the last few words and
changes that we hold these truths to be
self-evident and he wants to make the
point that it's the consent of the
governed from which
rights emerge their natural rights
rights of reason and rationality not
just rights endowed by religion and once
again that from that early silence
do-good sense of tolerance and
rationality and pragmatism you see it
reflected now in 1776 and that great
document they finally saw later that
year he goes to France to get France and
on our side and the Revolution I think
he was the last diplomat who really knew
how to handle the French and he did it
masterfully first of all he played a
wonderful balance of power he's a
realist he played a balance of power
gain a balance of power game that would
have dazzled a matter Nick or Kissinger
playing off the interests of Spain the
Netherlands France the Bourbon Pact
countries and England making it clear to
virgin who was in the Foreign Minister
and King Louie the 16th why was it
France's interest to be on the side but
more importantly he realized and this is
a key to what America is all about in
its role in the world and the role we're
gonna have to play in this new century
that the strength of America has been
always will be
and even when it won the Cold War its
strength was the appeal of its ideals
not just the force of its interests and
power that people like the ideals of
America the ideals of liberty aversion
to tyranny the things that Franklin
stood for and he he promotes these
throughout France he prints the
Declaration of Independence all the
state constitutions on this private
press that he creates in his in Paris
because he wants to inspire the French
people with the ideals of equality and
Liberty that are bubbling up so famously
in France at the time and he becomes the
most famous American ever in well with
all due respect to Jerry Lewis ever in
France and people are paying to see him
go through the streets are paying for
good spots on the street when he's being
brought to the Academy to hug Voltaire
and Franklin is no fool he's always
worrying about his image whether it be
about humility or industriousness
rolling the carts of paper through the
streets of Philadelphia
or his generosity and when he first
arrives here he knows that the French
sort of love Rousseau and the idea of
the natural man so here's a guy Benjamin
Franklin who really has lived in
Philadelphia in London his whole life on
Market Street and Craven Street for that
matter - well named streets but he
pretends to be the great backwoods Ben
as well and he wears the fur cap and the
frock coat from the backwoods and the
sort of and even when he goes into the
salons or whatever none of the wigs or
fancy ceremonial swords he's wearing his
fur cap and people are touching it and
thinking of him as a natural frontier
philosopher and they create all these
medallions and portraits of Franklin and
it just became the thing in Paris
everybody wearing Franklin medallions
it's so annoyed King Louie the sixteenth
and amused him that when one of the
countess's it was part of the court of
the King at the time kept going on and
on about Franklin and wearing the
medallion the King actually had a
chamber pot made with an embossed
Franklin medallion at the bottom for her
but it works france france's ideals are
appealed to its interests or appealed to
they come in on our side in the
revolution i don't think we would have
won militarily the way we did without
france i think 90% of the Gunpowder came
from france
certainly lafayette had as many troops
at Yorktown French troops as George
Washington did and emeril lagasse opted
off the retreat
Franklin was famous of course because
poor Richard had been collected and
published there as Lucinda bornholm
rashard and so they raised the money for
John Paul Jones to have a ship that
helps win the revolution and and in
gratitude he named it the bond homeless
yard after Benjamin Franklin by the way
there's another grid there's a great
book out by a friend of mine Evan Thomas
that describes the importance of John
Paul Jones and sort of the grandeur of
this crazed friend of Benjamin Franklin
in Paris some wonderful scenes of them
together in Paris but so France comes in
on our side in the revolution
becomes our savior and it it really
shows that of all the things Franklin
did great scientists you know great
writer everything else he was the most
accomplished diplomat and we have so
much to learn even from that on Benjamin
Franklin when he finally does come back
to America he's now about you know just
past 80 years old so that time for him
to retire but he doesn't they're
gathering here in Philadelphia to do the
Constitutional Convention and his
Jefferson once famously said of the
people who gathered they were sort of
demigods and Franklin was there to
remind them that they were actually in
the presence of a God greater than
themselves and of history and that all
these great heroic men of principle who
came here to Philadelphia and were so
dedicated to their principles that they
would compromise the whole conventions
almost breaking down on the question of
the large states wanting proportional
representation smaller states wanting
the equal vote for state in Congress
those type of issues and finally
Franklin the great stage becomes the
voice of compromise and what he says
basically is that compromisers may not
make great heroes but they do make great
democracies that's what democracy is all
about feeling that maybe the person
who's against you and fighting you on a
matter of principle maybe they have
something worth listening to as well and
maybe that's how you make a democracy he
said he'd do it the way when we were
young tradesmen and we tried to make a
joint that would fit together well for a
table or something and if it didn't
quite fit you'd have to shave a little
off of one plank and then take a little
off the other plank and you kept doing
that until you made a joint that would
hold together for centuries and so too
we have this convention must each part
with some of our demands and realize
with a little bit of humility that we
may be fallible and so they did and he
makes the motion that has a house and a
Senate and other things he also keeps
fighting for the notion of democracy
when most of the founders at the
councillors convention were a little bit
worried about the concept
to democracy he kept saying let's not do
anything that demeans the spirit of the
common citizen no wealth requirements to
be able to vote or hold office all that
sort of thing and he gets all these
things done as a compromise his
compromise is passed and then he makes
this wonderful closing speech which
everybody should read about why they
should all line up
even though who's even those who opposed
this document and sign it and he said
you know I'm getting old now is what he
basically says and I'm not sure that
this is the best of documents but in my
old age I realize that I may be wrong
and that some of the things I see as
flaws I may be mistaken and maybe this
is the best possible document and maybe
when you gather people together and you
get the wisdom of all people like this
you end up with a document that is near
as perfect as you can get as we've done
here today so let's put aside our
differences and admit some of our
fallibilities and not be so arrogant and
line up and sign it and make it
unanimous and so they did almost all of
them all except for a handful all line
up to sign the document that very hot
summer day in Philadelphia by the way
this is before air conditioning so
imagine today in this roaming yes and as
they line up and sign it he points to
the back of General Washington's chair
and he says I've often wondered whether
that was a rising or a Setting Sun
because artists have trouble in their
art distinguishing between the two but
now I know it's a Rising Sun they
finally opened the doors because they've
done this all behind closed doors one of
the grand old ladies of this town mrs.
Pownall comes up to him and says what
have you wrought what have you given us
what have you done in there and he says
the Republic madam if you can keep it
and that was his sense that was all
about democracy the wisdom of the common
citizen could be up to us to be able to
keep it there was however at that
convention and in Franklin's lifetime
one issue that could not be solved by
compromise and it was the issue that
they failed to solve it was the issue of
slavery and Franklin had fought Karen
his whole life but he had made many
errors in his life which is why I liked
him he was a flesh-and-blood founder as
I said the one who made errors admitted
to those errors and tried to rectify
them as he said so in his 80s after the
convention he decides to become
president of the Society for the
abolition of slavery because he had
owned two slaves once his life and he
did allowed his newspaper to carry
advertisements for slavery
and he realized that this was a blot in
a lifetime fat spent fighting tyranny so
he becomes president of the Society for
the abolition of slavery and does a
remarkable brilliant wonderful petition
and speech talking to Congress and
everybody else about the ideals of
America and how incompatible and
uncompromising ly incompatible they were
with slavery and how slavery had to be
abolished and all slaves freed etc a
congressman from Georgia got up right
afterwards after this thing is published
he gave this speech attacking Franklin
talking about how the economy would be
in trouble
if you didn't have slavery and how
slavery was needed and how the slaves
who were here were better off and that
sort of thing so from his deathbed last
thing a great thing he writes lying in
the deathbed here on Market Street
he writes yet again another wonderful
hoax that for a while fooled people and
in the paper he publishes he says that
he discovered and this is just echoes of
silence do-good at age 16 here he is in
his eighties discovered a speech given a
hundred years earlier in the divan of
algiers by the one of the great
legislators of algeria defending the
need to continue the practice of
enslaving white European Christians to
work in algeria and it goes step by step
through the arguments that have been
made defending slavery in america and
was quite a sensation and to me it was a
fitting into a life but ghana silence
do-good fighting against tyranny and all
forms of trampling of our rights making
our blood boil exceedingly to do that
parody in hoax the speech of the divine
of Algiers
on his deathbed and when in his lifetime
here in Philadelphia he had contributed
you look at his Ledger's to the building
fund of each and every Church in
Philadelphia and even at one point he
raised money for what was then called
the new Hall right next to what is now
Independence Hall and it was for
itinerant preachers preachers who wanted
to come in and didn't have a pulpit and
in the brochure in the pamphlet he
writes soliciting money for it he says
even if the mufti of Constantinople were
to send somebody here to preach Mohammed
to us we should give that person a
pulpit and you should have a place to
speak and we should listen and then
right before he dies he's the one of the
largest these are top three donors to
the mikveh Israel synagogue the building
fund of the first synagogue in
Philadelphia so in the day he died
when they bring his coffin to the grave
usually your Minister marches with the
coffin all the ministers and preachers
of all of Philadelphia and the rabbi of
the Jews all walked arm-in-arm holding
his coffin to the grave and that to me
is the spirit of Philadelphia and the
spirit of religious tolerance the spirit
of what Franklin gave us in the spirit
of what we need for our new century
thank you all very much
right
well I'm delighted to say that mr.
Isaacson is agreed to answer questions
and just as our tradition during our
other speaker series we have a volunteer
on each side with a microphone and we
want you to you know when you're ready
to when you want to ask a question raise
your hand
mr. Isaacson will call upon you but
please you do need the microphone so
that everybody can hear and that also it
will carry across the room Thanks yes
yes sir right there that's how you're
not in doing the speech worrying about
what you were gonna ask I forgot could
you comment on the portrayal of Franklin
in the recent book on John Adams by
David McCullough's book is a masterful
wonderful book I'm sure most of you have
read it I think everybody in America has
read it and I've always admired David
McCullough in fact asked him to read
some of this manuscript and my
manuscript and help on it a bit he bears
none of the blame for the problems in it
but he was helpful obviously there was a
complex love-hate relationship between
John Adams and Benjamin Franklin a
wonderful weird relationship it begins
as I said he comes back to 1776 at doing
the Declaration they're working together
Lord Hal has come over from England with
a peace feeler and he had played chess
and Franklin had tried to negotiate a
peace with him few years earlier and so
he sent it to Franklin Franklin gives it
to the Congress and they authorized
Franklin to go talk to him
but they're a little bit worried
especially John Adams that Franklin is
too much of an accommodator
a compromise so Adams travels with them
this is the first real bonding
experience a bonding experience because
they get there on the way to Staten
Island and they get to the end and
there's only one room with one bed so
they have to sleep in this bed together
and it's great cuz you see it in
Franklin's letters and in Adams as
Diaries Franklin had just come up with
the theory of the contagious nature of
the
which happens to be correct that that
colds were caused not by cold air but by
germs so he insists they keep the
windows open the entire time Adams who
it'll have none of it kept wanting to
close the window Franklin says I guess I
haven't explained to you my theory of
the contagious nature of cults and they
lying and bad news starts explaining and
Adams delightfully especially for Adams
who was not usually as humorous with all
as frankly SOTA said now after about
half an hour I finally fell asleep while
he was on and on about his contagious
there and so he thoughts won the
argument and they get to they work
together of course in France although
Adams gets himself kicked out for a
while and they have a great conflict
over how to deal with the French as I
said Franklin basically loved to seduce
people Nations the French he was going
to charm the French into understanding
that we shared ideals ah Adams was much
more of a realist hard-nosed not in any
way trying to charm the French but just
you know no suturing for alliances for
him and in fact one of the great
distinctions as Franklin famously learns
to speak French by lounging on the
pillows of his two great girlfriends
they are Madame hibiscus and Madame
Briana and exchanging little love notes
which they would correct his French and
John Adams learn French by memorizing
French funeral orations so you see the
difference in the way they don't but by
the end they share a couple of things a
deep patriotism and an enormous
intelligence and the greatest assessment
of Franklin in some ways comes after he
dies by John Adams I have it near the of
it in the in the book and conclusions
where Adams says look you know I just I
mean I'm paraphrasing but I was really
tough on this guy
and I had to be because he was the
greatest man of our time but in
retrospect and he gives us great pay on
to the greatness of Benjamin Franklin
and is a very nuanced understanding of
what made Franklin so special obviously
in my biography you know I'm a little
bit more partial to Franklin then David
McCullough was partial to Adams that's
why I recommend you read
both books yes in the in the middle and
like behind you first and up there I
haven't read your book yet but I was
wondering if you discovered something
about Franklin that something
significant that is not generally well
known and also something that we might
tribute to him that he may not have said
or done I think the most interesting
thing that's not all that well-known
about Franklin spent a lot of time
researching and had some help from a
researcher in London as well is the
notion that his secretary Edward
Bancroft while he was in Paris and
negotiating with the French and then the
British I was a British spy which has
been known but interestingly Bancroft
every Tuesday wrote reports exactly what
Franklin did what was happening in Paris
what was happening in the delegation
wonderful little things on John Adams by
the way he didn't like John Adams and he
wrote it an invisible ink in the blank
spaces between love letters and he put
it in a bottle in the toy regardons in a
hollowed-out tree and the British agent
would retrieve it and send it back to
London and they're all in the public
records office now in Britain and they
used a chemical wash to allow the
writing to come out so I went through
all of those to see exactly what was
being reported on and what happened to
Franklin one of the great things about
Franklin is he assumed any kind of knew
and he had been warned that there were
spies in his mess they assumed those
British spies and French spies and he
used it to his great advantage playing
them both off against each other when
he's about to conclude the peace treaty
the Treaty of Alliance I mean with
France to get them in on our side of the
Revolution he's letting knows the
British know exactly how far along he's
got and he's very open about it and the
person who's running the spy at Stormont
it comes over from London to try to
prevent this and wants to meet privately
with Franklin Silas Dean and some others
in the delegation and sends a note sort
of saying a friend wants to meet you you
know it's a very secretive spot
sort of thing and we'll meet you on the
side of the road at this part of the
road being in this type of carriage or
if not there in a bathhouse on the Seine
River in this cabin with a key that the
attendant will have and Silas Dean is
working with Franklin at the time and
frankly write back and say if you want
to meet you can come to our offices at
noon a response worthy of an American so
they just assumed they were very open
about things and it worked I mean they
played the British and French off
against each other masterfully but I
loved that wonderful spying stuff and I
as some of it has relegated to footnotes
because it was so rich but it would clog
up the narrative so it's buried there in
the footnotes but this spy and some of
the others were also speculating on the
stock market so before they sent the
word back to the British spy overlords
they were sending it to Wharton and of
the other bankers in London so they
could show it the stocks when things
were coming in and it just became a look
at both Franklin benignly assuming that
he was being spied upon and in some ways
a bit too
I think careless about it but still it
ended up working and what these spies
all did there's probably a lot of myths
that tributed to Franklin but in some
ways the opposite is more true you take
the electricity experiments and we think
of them as the doddering old sage
whatever the discovery of the single
fluid theory of electricity which is
basically Franklin's great insight is in
some ways the most important scientific
discovery of the time that and he even
invented the words we still use to
describe it positive and negative flow
battery condenser plus minus s or think
that electricity was a fluid and flowed
as opposed to what they called vitreous
and resinous and two separate fluids and
all sorts of crazy ways they were
looking at it plus he also believed that
what uses science would use his
philosophy if it doesn't lead to some
practical good he kept saying and so he
said at first he couldn't figure out
having done these great discoveries in
electricity what practical use they
would have he said so far it was two
things he used it at the end of one
season of experiments to build a huge
battery in which they jolted
and killed turkeys for their celebration
so we southerners like to think of him
as the inventor of the deep-fried turkey
they said really the only use we've
discovered for electricity so far is
that it helps make a vain man humble
because it's knocked us out all the time
but eventually he figures out okay the
charge and that the ability of pointed
objects to draw a charge from charged
bodies he figures out that lightning
comes from a excess of charge in a cloud
and it's a discharge and stuff so he
figures out the lightning rod and comes
up with a exponent which is basically
the most important technological
invention of the time I mean lightning
rods so you know it was an amazing thing
and saved the world
so I've scored it answering your
question about where he was overrated to
give you a chance to give myself a
chance to talk about in some ways I
think his electricity discoveries are
underrated way in the back there I'm
sorry I this gentleman here and then way
in the back end could you comment on the
rumors or the stories that are going
around I believe prompted by your book
that the kite and key story was a hoax
there's a project there's other books
out about it I don't know there's one
book and I'm not quite sure it sort of
says maybe it was a hoax it's not quite
clear well there's a great book for
those who are interested in the kite
experiment how he reported it why he
held off reporting it for a while etc
there is one great book about all of the
science two books actually by the same
guy it puts it all in perspective I
Bernhard Cohen who just died not too
long ago but wrote Franklin and Newton
and I like the order in which he put it
and then Benjamin Franklin's science
which explained I think in great detail
because he published Franklin scientific
papers the whole kite experiment issue
but there's obviously been some debate
on historians because he doesn't report
it right away and it's important to note
that he never claimed that his
experiment was the first to discover
this he created an experiment that was
basically a lightning rod type thing to
draw a lightning from the clouds he
published it as how it should be done
and it was done in France because they
were able to build a platform the Sentry
box is done in a village
marlee friends because the king at the
time was had been shown Benjamin
Franklin's experiments was so excited by
it he commissioned them to try this
century box lightning rod experiment
it's successful he becomes the most
famous person in the world because of it
he's celebrated all over it gets back to
Philadelphia a couple months later that
this has been this huge success and then
a month or so after that I think it is
he says it's great it was done in France
and congratulate him he said after they
did it just sort of a by the way we
found another way it could be done
instead of erecting this whole century
box which is to put up the wire on a
kite and draw it down the string of a
kite so his description of the kite
experiment was not supposed to be the
first drawing of lightning from the
clouds experiment and he only reports it
after he learns they've already done in
France and doesn't claim it was the
first one but it's a rather complicated
thing and there are some debates about
when and how and why and there are many
books including a recent one but also as
I say going back to the I Bernhard Cohen
work on his science yes back there was
it and I think you have to wait for the
mic which is right behind you Carl Van
Doren who wrote an earlier biography of
Franklin write it right before World War
two or right after it 1930 ray - ok it
was yeah he called Franklin a harmonious
human multitude and my question is it
was a much better writer than I was
carving Doron English and your books
coming out about Franklin D do do you
think that you and Morgan any other
authors have a more complicated view of
the harmonious human multitude I mean I
tried to take him as a very human person
just say the call van Doorn book is a
masterpiece it's an English you know he
was an English professor and really is
particularly good as Franklin the writer
and stuff I was more interested in the
multiple facets of the man and his life
including his family life but also his
diplomacy his science his newspaper work
his creation of a great media empire
things that I felt tied end
our period today I think there's been
Morgan has a unbelievably insightful
book that came out a couple of years
about a year ago I guess it is now that
a reading of all the papers one of the
things that's happened well since Van
Doren's 1930s biography is that all of
Franklin's papers have been collected at
Yale or almost all of them there's that
I think it's 47 volumes they're gonna do
and they're up to about 37 right now in
fact it's on a cd-rom that's not yet in
the lease but you know I've been able to
you know they'll lend out and so you can
read everything he wrote and even search
it by phrase or keyword that sort of
thing and so it does help the
exploration of Franklin but more
importantly and I try to do this in my
last chapter I look at how each
generation each decade even has looked
at Benjamin Franklin and each generation
because he's the most human of the
founding fathers the most delightful of
the founding fathers each generation we
see ourselves reflected in him Carl Van
Doren wrote his book during the
Depression it had come after a Romantic
era when people like D H Lawrence were
making fun of Benjamin Franklin is and
all that penny saved is a penny earned
stuff as being frugal penny-pinching
Maxim's and thrifty little things that
we didn't able to deed to deal with and
then you look in the depression and
people like Paul Van Doren taking them
on and it shifts and I think our
generation each generation should look
in new at Franklin not only because of
the inspiring values we get from him but
that flesh-and-blood sense of the person
and even his flaws and we can see an
ambitious urban entrepreneur somebody
who very comfortable in an Information
Age somebody comfortable with technology
a great network or a great you know many
things you can see reflected for better
and for worse in our times and so
although I love people to read you know
call Van Doren and certainly ed Morgan
and certainly H of your brand's many
people have done really great books I
make no apologies for the fact that you
know we should write about Benjamin
Franklin often especially as he's about
to celebrate his 300th birthday right
which needs a microphone it's part of
the question which was how would you
like to see us celebrate the 300th in
2006 I think it's gonna be celebrated
very well there's a consortium here in
Philadelphia I think I'm going to lunch
tomorrow with some of them they're doing
an unbelievably good job the Franklin
Institute the American Philosophical
Society of Anneliese I'm about universe
opposed vania Library company huh many
others have formed a consortium the
government is not helping enough but
helping some to fund it and we're gonna
be talking about that and I would
suggest that what Franklin would want is
for a lot of people to give a lot of
input because he believed that you know
part of celebrations like this was
inclusiveness and making us all feel
like citizens I have my ideas which is
you know we should look at the effect
that he has today on a variety of fields
from technology to science to
information to freedom to fight against
tyranny and most importantly at all as
of all as was the theme of my talk
tonight the celebration of religious
tolerance and pluralism that makes our
country strong in the world today and I
think there are many ways to do that
both through exhibitions and panels and
discussions
I don't want to preempt that because
there are people who are much better at
figuring these things out who are
working on at night I'm flattered to be
invited to be with them tomorrow and
talk to them but I don't know what
they're planning but the small things I
do know about what they're planning is
it's gonna be a hell of a good birthday
party
yes ma'am over there
so much how many years of research and
writing did it take you and my curiosity
leads me to ask you also if you are
thinking of or planning another book at
this time a writing no at this time well
I've spent I've been working on my for
Henry Kissinger and was interested in
the roots of realism in American foreign
policy but also the fact that Kissinger
was a great balance of power realist but
I don't think had a fingertip feel for
the openness democracy and values that
lead the true strength and in a foreign
policy so I was looking for the root of
the idealism and so it was even back
then that I had been reading Benjamin
Franklin a lot because he's the first
great diplomat to do it and then I
became as a person involved in the
publishing Empire quite interested in
him that way
so starting 12 or so years ago I was
studying him seriously my whole life
like many people you just absolutely
smitten and fascinated by Benjamin
Franklin and you feel you have to rescue
yourself from having read the
autobiography in school and figuring out
ok the autobiography has many many
layers and he created a delightful
character in the autobiography that he
named Benjamin Franklin but that doesn't
necessarily mean that that was exactly
who Benjamin Franklin was so I did it
for 12 years I had some day jobs in that
period and some of which made me want to
get arrested at night and was a lot of
fun I mean you know people said some
people ask you how do you do well a
labor of love it's like you know
building a model ship or playing golf
some people love doing things that you
know they'll spend a lot of time on I'd
spend a lot of my evenings you know
starting and he said early to bed early
to rise you know makes a man etcetera I
found that a lot of hooey I used to just
start work at 9 o'clock at night and
work until I got really really tired and
but it was fun and if you start reading
Benjamin Franklin you say beau that was
fun you can see what you do speaking of
which the next thing I think I'm gonna
do and want to do with my publisher and
get together is one of the problems of
Benjamin Franklin is you can read the
autobiography your de bookstore there's
all sorts of paperback copies of the
autobiography been doing Frank but if
you want to read the things I was
talking about the silence do-good
letters or the busybody essay
so the apology for printers or a poor
richard's almanack and all the preface
--is and all the Maxim's or Polly
Baker's trial or the edict from the King
of Prussia or the witch trial at Mount
Holly or the speech to the divine of
Algiers on white Christian slavery you
can't really find that that easily
there's a great Library of America
edition came out 15 20 years ago but
it's you know expensive is not right so
I'd like to put together the best
writings of Benjamin Franklin and if
anybody's curiosity was piqued over the
past few years by the various books that
have come out on Benjamin Franklin maybe
you go back to the real thing now and he
can say it better than we ever did and
so I hope by the end of the year we'll
put out a nice and and inexpensive you
know anthology of his best writings
anymore I do want to say Benjamin front
dr. Franklin is actually with us I saw
him walk in and so if you have more
questions in the very back Philadelphia
has there's a great pride and I won't
take them out of character I'll just
call him dr. Franklin somebody who
answers questions about dr. Franklin
better than anybody I've ever seen do it
so further questions can be directed at
dr. Franklin's standing in the Pacific
in the back thank you all very much
Walter Isaacson is president of the
Aspen Institute Benjamin Franklin that
American life is published by Simon &
Schuster on the web at Simon Says
dot-com